c'est essentiel que légalement et que
les problèmes budget parce que justin
trudeau a augmenté le dernier tiers des
milliards et des milliards d'euros et le
résultat est que plus en plus de votre
argent
allez allez les banques pour l'intérêt
sur le dire que disent les chiffres au
sujet de la dette canadienne et des
intérêts qu'il faut payer pour la
rembourser
[Musique]
depuis l'arrivée justin trudeau la dette
fédérale est passé de 616 à 686
milliards une augmentation de 70
milliards de dollars sur ce point le
chef conservateur a donc entièrement
raison mais le canada paie-t-il de plus
en plus d'intérêt aux banques comme
l'affirmé mme joshi heures voyons voir
quand les libéraux ont pris le pouvoir
le fédéral a payé cette année-là 25
milliards de dollars pour les frais de
la dette
quatre ans plus tard les intérêts ont
coûté 23 milliards de dollars donc entre
le début et la fin du mandat libéral les
intérêts ont coûté 2 milliards de
dollars 2 - essentiellement parce que
les taux d'intérêt sont plus bas cela
dit depuis deux ans oui les frais de la
dette ont recommencé à augmenter et plus
la dette
plus les taux d'intérêt augmentent plus
à risque de coûter cher
cependant selon le fonds monétaire
international la gestion de la dette
canadienne est loin d'être un problème
au contraire
le canada est à l'échelle mondiale dans
ce domaine un premier de classe
en fait le poids de la dette par rapport
à l'économie canadienne est de loin le
plus bas de tous les pays du g7